Today's episode is sponsored by Copy That,
an addictive memory game. Make sure you stay
till the end of the video to find out how
you can win a brand new Iphone 7. Take a look
at the 4 squares on the screen. The squares
will glow in a particular order. When the
words your turn appear, play along and copy
the sequence. Ready? Here are the answers.
How did you do? Sequence A on average can
be done by 6 year olds. Sequence B by 8 year
olds and Sequence C by 11 year olds. This
test is called the knox cube test developed
by howard andrew knox to measure nonverbal
intelligence in children. It turns out how
well children do on this test is positively
correlated with their IQs later in life. It
is also said to measure short term memory
and attention span. So I decided to do a similar
test on myself who has a college degree in
psychology and my cousin, who is in high school.
I can already tell this is going to be embarrassing.
Instead of using the knox cube test. We'll
be playing the game, Copy That which takes
this test to the extreme. How old are you?
I'm 14. So you're in high school right? yeah.
how do you think your memory is? It's pretty
good, I guess. Some things I forget. I have
a bad memory, I think I'm going to lose. bam
level 2. this game is unfair. what the heck.
maybe its your phone. your screen is so dirty
right now. Thanks Jewel. Oh my gosh. Why wasn't
I paying attention? Obviously I am horrible
at this game and my memory is horrible, but
its your turn. Please please mess up. She
beat my level already. What the heck? It's
not hard. Lame. its not fair. how? how is
this happening? your phone is really hot.
My phone is recording what you're playing.
Oh crap. Oh my. Well that's it. I was beat
by a high school student. Here are some tips
to help you improve your memory and to even
improve your score on this game. Wish I had
known these before I played. Tip number one,
chunk it. If you're from the United States,
telephone numbers come in ten digit bundles
like this. Research has shown the brain to
only hold 7 pieces of information in short
term memory, but when chunked together like
this it can hold more. you can do the same
with the game by imagining the first three
steps as one chunk, the second as another
chunk, and so on. Tip number 2 organize it.
I'm going to show you a list of words for
10 seconds. Try and memorize as much as you
can before time is up. Now pause the video
and try to recall them. chances are you what
helped you memorize the words was by categorizing
them by fruits and furniture. you can try
this out in the game as well, whether it be
by number of steps like the first five or
area the circles appear. So I hope you use
these tips to your advantage. Whether its
memorizing information for a test or beating
my cousin's high score. Don't forget to check
out the link for the game down in the description
below. They support psych2go and help us make
better videos for you. The makers of copy
that have also been kind enough you guys a
chance to win an Iphone 7. Just download the
app below and click on the link for the contest
rules. See ya